[Music]
we went through this whole thing at la
carrera and left at the end of March and
the woman I was with and I stayed in
Colombia another month everybody else
went back and we wrestled with it
another month and I was quite out of it
I think I believed that she would give
birth to the word itself and I believed
that it would be a little glass fianc
bead that I had lost in Laos five years
earlier and when she began to develop a
round sore on the top of her mouth that
was exactly the size of this thing
then I realized that this little object
would drop down onto her tongue
someday soon and she would deliver it to
me and that it would be the Word made
flesh it would be the now are you
alarmed now now do you begin to get the
trips that we've attempted to suppress
[Music]
I was flaming and it's take it took me
years and years to dial it down so that
it's even as friendly and package'
Balazs it is in the Crescent moment
because for a long time it wasn't I mean
it just drove people to the walls I mean
they just said I don't know and I don't
want to hear anything I've had it I call
me when you're better
[Music]